it's the final season what are you both
feeling right now
i am feeling sorry
i i am feeling um
very emotional about it i i will be
honest uh it's very bittersweet to see
something that you
care so much about that that has been
such a big part of your life sort of
come to an end in a way um it feels like
just yesterday that we were starting
this show
but i do feel so proud of what we've
created and it's been a very
um
very emotional
uh journey for for us all i think in the
best way possible but i'm very excited
that it's it's coming out in
the fans will get their final chapter to
the story
anna what about you
yeah
same i'm feeling just kind of grateful
all over again that i ever got to do it
in the first place
and i'm remembering back uh to one of
the last days that we all shot together
and i thought it was a genius idea for
everyone to go to a russian vodka room
and we all ended up crying how much we
love doing the show
um and so i'm now just so excited to
share it with other people because it
feels like i get to relive
making this beautiful thing with people
who have become such great friends
yeah
haley what part of playing emily will
stay with you in real life
uh i mean i'll tell you that there are
very few parts that won't um
playing this
this
powerhouse of a
female of this of a literary icon
um who
rarely took no for an answer who
constantly fought against all the
constraints that she was faced with
in her time and in general uh that we
find are somewhat similar to maybe some
that we still have to face today um
i am forever inspired by this character
and i
will always
always think back to i think how
if she got through what she got through
in the time that she lived through yeah
then i can
i can do a whole lot right now and i'm
i'm so grateful for that i'm so grateful
for this show um
for introducing me to her and for for um
you know the fact that she is now in
integrated into my life uh at the level
that she is i will never take that for
granted and i'm just so grateful so yeah
yeah
um anna for you i know that you studied
uh demi moore for this role what about
watching them he helped you with this
character
um that yeah that was in in
reference to the
when in the season two there was a
little scarlet letter role play scene
yeah and because the show jumps between
you know has modern references in it
and elena had had said that in the
writer's room they watched the scene
from
jimmy moore's version of the scarlet
letter that
um and so i thought it would be fun to
kind of try to affect my voice a little
like hers just as kind of like an easter
egg for anyone
um
who's seen the movie and in that same
season you know i had a
little verbatim
words um from pretty woman i spoke one
of richard gere gear's lines and i think
there's a fun thing about lavinia that
she dips in and out of using some of the
most modern language on the show and so
um yeah there are definitely some some
versions of that in season three as well
and i think it just keeps me
on my toes in terms of
keeping the material unexpected and
fresh
i love that thank you for your time guys
thank you thank you thank you so much
you